Over at microcosmos.store, you can pick up
your very own Microcosmos Microscope.
It comes with four Plan Objectives to ensure
the sharpest possible image and using the
included phone mount, you can capture images
like the ones you’re seeing right now, all
of which were recorded on our microscope.
Check it out today at microcosmos.store
In the 1820s, a man named Dr. R. Brandes walked
through a meadow on a quest to try and answer
a centuries-old question that had recently
begun to spark discussion among his own correspondences.
Several of his acquaintances had come across
masses of a mysterious gelatinous substance
on the ground known as “star jelly,” but
no one knew what it could possibly be.
But on the list of possibilities was this:
a bacteria called nostoc.
Our first discoveries of bacteria are generally
credited to Robert Hooke and Antoni van Leeuwenhoek,
who wielded their microscopes to explore the
invisible worlds embedded in our surroundings
and reported back with descriptions of tiny,
living things.
Their work goes back to the 17th century,
relatively recent as far as human endeavors
go.
And yet our knowledge of nostoc is much, much
older, going back at least 1,600 years, when
they featured in Chinese writings describing
their use as food.
And somehow the bacteria was named “nostoc”
in the 16th century, before we knew that bacteria
existed.
But how?
How could we know about a bacteria before
we knew their type existed?
How could we see them, let alone eat them
or name them or write about them?
How could someone like Dr. Brandes possibly
look at a lump of jelly on the ground and
think it has anything to do with the little
dots we need a microscope to see right now?
Well, it’s because nostoc don’t actually
live as a single little set of dots on their
own.
They are part of something larger than them,
much much larger.
They exist as a colony, a mass of nostoc held
together like these ones.
Nostoc are cyanobacteria, and the individual
cells are usually shaped like spheres or ovals.
These cells are attached to each other, forming
the short strands we can see here, which are
called trichomes.
But not all of the cells of the nostoc are
the same.
Life in a colony means that different cells
can take on different tasks instead of having
to try and accomplish everything at once.
Some specialize in reproduction, while others
fix nitrogen to help the cells grow.
And some rare cells remain dormant behind
thick walls.
Their main task is survival, ensuring the
nostoc colony can grow from something again
should environmental conditions take a turn
for the worse.
There are several hundred species of Nostoc
that we know of, and there is a wide range
of sizes to those colonies.
Some are only a few millimeters in diameter,
while others—
like Nostoc pruniforme—
can get up to 22 centimeters in diameter.
What holds the trichomes together so they
can accumulate into these larger sizes is
a gelatinous matrix made of sugars.
We’ve actually been staring at this jelly
structure the entire time, but it’s hard
to see because the cells within it are so
still.
The gelatinous shell just melts into the background.
But you can see it here.
Or rather, you see the jelly shell being poked
and prodded at by a creature on the other
side of it.
That matrix does more than hold the colony
together.
It protects it, keeping it safe from solar
radiation and other dangers in the environment.
And as you may have guessed, the gelatinous
structure is the magic behind the mystery
mucus piles that people have found lying on
the ground.
In fact, the name “nostoc” is a round-about
tribute to those squishy lumps.
In the 16th century, there was a scientist
and alchemist named Aureolus Philippus Theophrastus
Bombastus von Hohenheim, though he’s become
known by the much shorter “Paracelsus.”
Paracelsus was particularly fascinated by
folklore, and as he traveled throughout Western
Europe, he often looked to talk to peasants
and craftsmen and others who might be able
to tell him about things like “witch’s
jelly,” another phrase used to describe
nostoc.
Paracelsus was the one who gave the organism
the name it’s known by today, drawing on
Old English and German words for nostril.
The inspiration for choosing a variation on
“nostril” comes, we assume, from the very
booger-like appearance of the nostoc, the
clumpy green masses they form along the ground.
One 17th century writer described nostoc as
“excrement blown from the nostrils of some
rheumatick planet, falling upon spacious plains,
fields and sheep pastures.”
The fascination with nostoc came because their
lumpy, jelly bodies seemed to come out of
nowhere, but were often associated with rain
or shooting stars.
It’s why their numerous names include things
like “spittle of the stars” and “star
slime.”
We now know why nostoc are capable of such
surprising appearances.
It’s not that they come from nowhere.
Rather they come from a dry, desiccated state
that renders them brittle and dark against
the ground, and thus easily missed.
They survive these times thanks in part to
the sugars surrounding them, which keep them
protected from this dry state.
And when it rains, their bodies fill with
water, expanding the matrix and thus the colony
into something we can see and touch and feel
(and yes, sometimes even eat).
So when Dr. Brandes investigated the meadow
for the masses of gelatinous lumps he found
there, nostoc was a distinct possibility.
One apothecary he cited found a Nostoc species
on the ground that sounded similar in some
ways.
But his mass was different.
It was a very distinct white color, and it
looked more like frog eggs, though not quite.
He did what anyone obsessed with a frustrating
identification problem would do and dove into
the literature, coming out with a conclusion:
what he had found was snail spawn.
And who are we to dissuade him?
It sounds like our nostoc weren’t responsible
for the jelly masses he found.
Which is an altogether anticlimactic ending,
we suppose.
But we kind of like that.
Because over and over again, people find their
version of star jelly, and sometimes it is
snail spawn.
Sometimes it’s frog spawn that’s been
regurgitated by a bird.
One time, it even turned out to be waste from
a battery treatment plant.
And every once in a while, it’s even nostoc.
Because while the microcosmos isn’t the
answer to everything, it remains a possibility
nonetheless.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds
us.
The people on the screen right now, they are
our Patreon patrons.
I appreciate them so much and I'm glad to
be making content again and I have also been
happy to see so many other hosts here on Journey
to the Microcosmos.
It's been a great time and I am always fascinated
by what we discover here.
So thank you so much to everybody who supports
us.
If you want to be one of these people, you
can go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.